Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When we look at the cover page of a magazine,
we often see lots of well-made, but also idealized
photos of people.
Idealized here means that the photographer
made them in a studio, where they can add
or remove light sources and move them around
to bring out the best from their models.
But most photos are not made in the studio,
they are made out there in the wild where
the lighting is what it is, and we can’t
control it too much.
So, with that, today, our question is what
if we could change the lighting after the
photo has been made?
This work proposes a cool technique to perform
exactly that by enabling us to edit the shadows
on a portrait photo that we would normally
think of deleting.
Many of these have to do with the presence
of shadows, and you can see here that we can
really edit these after the photo has been
taken.
However, before we start taking a closer look
at the editing process, we have to note that
there are different kinds of shadows.
One, there are shadows cast on us by external
objects, let’s call those foreign shadows,
and there is self-shadowing, which comes from
the model’s own facial features.
Let’s call those facial shadows.
So why divide them into two classes?
Simple, because we typically seek to remove
foreign shadows, and edit facial shadows.
The removal part can be done with a learning
algorithm, provided that we can teach it with
a lot of training data.
Let’s think about ways to synthesize such
a large dataset!
Let’s start with the foreign shadows.
We need image pairs of test subjects with
and without shadows to have the neural network
learn about their relations.
Since removing shadows is difficult without
further interfering with the image, the authors
opted to do it the other way around.
In other words, they take a clean photo of
the subject, that’s the one without the
shadows, and then, and add shadows to it algorithmically.
Very cool!
And, the results are not bad at all, and get
this, they even accounted for subsurface scattering,
which is the scattering of light under our
skin.
That makes a great deal of a difference.
This is a reference from a paper we wrote
with scientists at the University of Zaragoza
and the Activision Blizzard company to add
this beautiful effect to their games.
Here is a shadow edge without subsurface scattering,
quite dark, and with subsurface scattering,
you see this beautiful glowing effect.
Subsurface scattering indeed makes a great
deal of difference around hard shadow edges,
so huge thumbs up for the authors for including
an approximation of that.
However, the synthesized photos are still
a little suspect.
We can still tell that they are synthesized.
And that is kind of the point.
Our question is “can the neural network
still learn the difference between a clean
and a shadowy photo” despite all this?
As you see, the problem is not easy - previous
methods did not do too well on these examples
when you compare them to the reference solution.
And let’s see this new method.
Wow, I can hardly believe my eyes.
Nearly perfect.
And it did learn all this on not real, but
synthetic images.
And believe it or not, this was only the simpler
part.
Now comes the hard part.
Let’s look at how well it performs at editing
the facial shadows!
We can pretend to edit both the size and the
intensity of these light sources.
The goal is to have a little more control
over the shadows in these photos, but, whatever
we do with them, the outputs still have to
remain realistic.
Here are the before and after results.
The facial shadows have been weakened, and
depending on our artistic choices, we can
also soften the image a great deal.
Absolutely amazing.
As a result, we now have a two-step algorithm,
that first, removes foreign shadows, and is
able to soften the remainder of the facial
shadows, creating much more usable portrait
photos of our friends, and all this after
the photo has been made.
What a time to be alive!
Now, of course, even though this technique
convincingly beats previous works, it is still
not perfect.
The algorithm may fail to remove some highly
detailed shadows, you can see how the shadow
of the hair remains in the output.
In this other output, the hair shadows are
handled a little better, there is some dampening,
but the symmetric nature of the facial shadows
here put the output results in an interesting
no man’s land where the opacity of the shadow
has been decreased, but the result looks unnatural.
I can’t wait to see how this method will
be improved two more papers down the line.
I will be here to report on it to you, so
make sure to subscribe and hit the bell icon
to not miss out
on that.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!